botar o talentoso a minha presença em
uma sala à vista porque eu sei que se
fala hoje só vão cair mauá e deve ser
desconfortável essa lista é muito melhor
mas pelo menos é menos confortável ano
salta à vista é uma é uma referência a
única forma que eu saí por salvar as
coisas que é que a visita o olho que é
mais ou menos como faço tudo na vida eu
eu gosto muito pensar nas coisas penso
durante muito tempo mas quando chega a
altura de se dirigir à vista ou intuição
instinto alguns em especial a gente tem
tanto faz fazemos fazendo assim fiz na
minha carreira toda assim como enfim
consenso possível
o livro falar eu quero falar sobre o
extinto ou esse lugar entre instituição
que eu acho fundamental para para quem
utilizar debater idéias e na verdade o
que eu podia fazer é explicar o que é
super importante porque faz da mota
conseguir coisas e nos fins do que nunca
ninguém disso e com isso e intuição eram
muito mais do que certo
no meu caso - estou sempre errado está
em desenvolver o livro paulinho é paulo
e pomba cabeça na parede
eu faço de vida toda aí oito em cada vez
cabeça na empresa e duas vezes é o sítio
certo
a parte engraçada lista encabeçada por
ele e que não estão mais ou menos o que
eu aprendi a me bater com a cabeça no
planeta ao longo dos últimos 15 anos é
que o meu conforto não há vontade com o
saber por que eu tenho que mexer no
aparelho oito em cada dez vezes
é também uma relação a um direto com a
minha capacidade de evoluir e progredir
e portanto um toque microfone
estamos em época de copa e portanto a
minha capacidade ruído tv com tv como a
capacidade de reconhecer os erros melhor
a forma como eu consigo conviver com os
erros têm uma relação diretamente
proporcional com com a capacidade que a
sociedade evoluída e portanto em vez de
nos mostrar as coisas mais lindas que
fiz na vida é sempre uma coisa é
indiscutível que você pode não gostar
muito e fico triste ranking das piores
coisas que fiz na vida isso é assim a
coisa não podia e não podia que uma vez
a torcida
isto é muito mau vemos região cala pior
das hipóteses é pior o pior dos
jogadores ea partir daqui é sempre a
subir e portanto é uma situação
o hino indo pra toda dizendo vocês não
sabem mas tem muita mauá
eu vou mostrar coisas absolutamente
miseráveis que fiz ao longo da vida e
portanto vamos começar com o kalil que
eu fiz para um banco que entretanto
faliu vocês vão perceber por que começou
aqui começou aqui a falência
o lacre da guia estavam trânsito
carência
falou o que é estranho nas costas a
assistir é o irs
o dem sabe que o irs é um fato que todos
temos que ter lugar por isso lembra que
até 31 de dezembro se subscrever no
brasil pedro e é um plano de
compensações uma conta poupança
habitação os três ainda podem aproveitar
os benefícios fiscais e reduzir no fala
se eu iria
quem sabe eu mexo sabe não só eu tenho
fé na altura era mais novo tinha 23 anos
não só achei que era giro dizer que a
reação fato palha como é que é possível
as pessoas quando vão conduzir o vírus
pode cada e perceber que aqui é o senhor
que ele faz tem um fato para as costas
só estúpidos
ninguém percebeu este anúncio incluindo
o meu servo e incluindo um senhor que na
altura mandava no banco contava em ficar
só olhava que que ouviu ou viu a
campanha no ar ficou furioso perguntou à
senhora bateu quem é que fazer essa obra
é uma empresa e foram perguntando quem é
que tinha feito o cocô até chegar ao meu
chefe me perguntou quem foi feliz
muito bom continuando na longa lista de
bancos que eu conseguir fazer ao longo
da vida vamos agora o viram um outro
spot também fizemos foi bp já agora
conseguir quatro quebras que se na nossa
praça vamos ouvir um outro pacote ainda
pior do que este para um banco que
entretanto morreu chamado bic e depois
relaxe e nunca conseguiu vencer o mesmo
não vai gastar tudo quero verde pertence
ao oeste
eu acho que isso não é nada
as nossas coisas e sempre é melhor pedir
uma segunda opinião do especialista com
muitos o também no crédito à habitação
vão mais pedir uma segunda opinião do
especialista o banco internacional de
crédito o seu banco particular do grupo
banco espírito santo nem consegue ser
estúpido é normal
há certamente um médico que estava com
uma pessoa daquela máquina pip era uma
maioria absoluta móvel realizar e
pensamos que não é seu sócio do vidro
vender para vender crédito à habitação
mas é bom
continuando a minha longa carreira de
falhanço graças a um instinto tanto mais
cabeça na parede
vamos agora ouvir mais um bocado também
muito jeitoso promark telecomunicações
que também já não existe
graças a deus então eu falei agora mais
ou menos no ano foi enfim é fã
vamos ouvir falar no vídeo ao lado de um
telemóvel perder muito mais disso
os contactos das mensagens dos jogos as
fotografias e tudo o resto por isso teve
entre o basquete o primeiro subscritor
guardar uma cópia dos conteúdos do
telemóvel em tmn tvtel ktm grátis na
compra de uma nokia 6700
portanto tal serviço de backup
telemóveis
o senhor deixou cair o telemóvel não ana
tamanho lama pra que eu poder fazer
brincadeira com até o down está na lama
por que o senhor tinha uma fotografia do
alan e pps no recinto
nunca ninguém devia ter provado depois
que o brasileiro fazer isso é muito ruim
ainda há pessoas que pagam pra eu fazer
isso essa estúpida mas pronto
ah e não contente com o assunto também
tentando afundar também é traçar um
padrão aqui se algum dia precisar
incluir um bairro que só falem comigo e
eu faço isso para vocês quando não
contente com o assunto continue e na
altura difícil fiz mais um mais um
bocado e prometo que o último vamos ver
para uma trama para uma banca os pernas
de net neto móvel com velocidade
estonteante de 165 coisas vão mal cairá
1 mega por segundo
é fascinante ver não era bem um mega
2018 mas eu levo jeito que eu tenho medo
daí meu estilo disse que vai ser muito
bom eu escrevi isso e eu escrevi isto a
velocidade como ela é bom eu só queria
dizer pra mim isto vai dar merda pra mim
vai da mega pronto que propõe quando
estiverem todos na mega não virem dizer
que não avisei que tinha da mega
mas que história da mega vai é que só
podem mega vai ser meio tom para se
relacionar com a banda larga tmn mas não
ficaram 1,86 bits por segundo por apenas
39 11 90 por mês
a banda larga tmn
mohamed rápida da pm é desejar diz que a
amiga e disse você tenha razão
eles afirmam também que a onda que já
era a enfim mas a partir disto e altura
quando fiz isto não conseguia dizer que
teerã quer uma mega e que o diga quanto
mais velho vou ficando mais à vontade
vou ficando com como é difícil e não
aprendi muito com continuar a fazer isso
queria até o fim um bom
continuando eu fiz um jogo no dia a
seguir
já a provisão para uma marca de
hambúrgueres conhecem a minha cabeça em
letras que tomou e este só amanhã é mais
um daqueles que só estranho não percebo
não se percebe porque é que eu fiz isso
que você quer agir são luís - a conversa
e tal
é por causa do estado começar a andar um
crisa e tal e coisa foi a 1 que tem duas
é um que não tem nenhuma a um explica
basto tem duas e nós somos hoje porque
eu só tenho e outras coisas dizer eu
nunca fui muito bom em matemática mas
era tão mal que nem os atores quiseram
fazer isso então nesse ponto fica calado
vamos ver para perceberem a mesma coisa
se essas duas tardes de uma sã custar um
euro i e não somos os dois do rio
eu era meu
o que não estou inclinado
tá
quero conhecer melhor o nascedouro e
hoje é essa essência magníficos frutas
proteínas como eu não quero é uma
guerreira fazer este ps bom é e enfim
mais uma série de resolver poupar os de
22 anos foram passando e eu fui
aprendendo a e santa marta começa a
aprender a polir a mega que faço e
portanto fica uma mega poluída que
apesar tudo custa custa menos a ver não
deixa de ser melhor para quem sabe que a
mídia que nós vamos fingir portanto
fazendo coisas novas e isso é algo muito
maior pois há aquelas coisas muito boas
que eu achei que vão trazer um novo
conceito da marca vai subindo e quando
falar em cima e faz pronto cocó kokay
muito mais alto
depois quando chega acaba de trazer
muito mais coisas como por exemplo isso
que vamos ver se já vamos ver porque a
língua inglesa um instrumento para o
problema para outras
um dos prédios e veículos silencioso que
ataca quando menos se espera e quando
mais precisava e que pode ter efeitos
secundários do pastor
eu avisei plantas que fazem as palavras
tratos em inglês no 11 3755 evento vá
além dos três pontos como este é um erro
meu instinto isso o país tem muito é
muito bom e eu fiz isso e tal
e vocês você estava muito anos os
publicitários publicitários temos um ego
gigante e unb no eu me totalmente on
line mas temos muitos festivais e
estamos juntando se a premissa os outros
e tal pois ficamos muito contentes e
esta campanha que vocês vêem ganhou
todos os prêmios que enganaram se vai
ficar na terra e mesmo alguns na américa
latina e em roma mas não sei que tanto
eu achei bem distinto desta vez
acertamos no final do ano este cliente
ou assistindo não tenha vendido por
nenhuma causa dessa campanha e tirou
contra a agência não fluir mas quase
ela está aí tem aqui o erro que é mais
difícil ver tanta gente vai ficando mais
velho
vamos aprimorando aquilo que fazemos e
fica mais difícil distinguir aquilo que
é 31 de julho claramente joelho não fez
defendeu eu gostar de movimentos
pequenos nas costas dos amigos e colegas
não fez ninguém entrar não sei falar aos
37 de dizer eu quero aprender inglês que
era aquilo que é suposto fazer porque o
projeto faz anúncios e na outra coisa e
terminar em grande uma campanha é voltar
a um filme dessa campanha que é
exatamente o mesmo problema que esta é a
primeira que esta última de wall street
mas piora um pouco
foi ainda mais premiada e eu consegui
convencer toda a gente incluindo o
cliente que estava com o rebanho
a campanha teve um ar durante dois anos
em maio a marca de telemóveis projetou
nova norma o técnico agora móvel que
começa em ver as letras nomeadamente
para as para o seu segmento para
segmento jovem começa aí
só acaba em letras ora a rã e vamos ver
se depois que já ficam do que aconteceu
o negócio renda fixa diz a isso nossa
ênfase com nota
eu tinha dito não esquece a senhora está
nas 3 ganha tablets e telemóveis e bonde
que godói até julho com 16 anos a mais
que o sexo logo embora os 6 euros e o
gol depois airton net usar o código e
ganhar ainda mais pra eles e didi estava
a falar em gozo e tomba vive negociado é
uma coisa que estava fazendo lá em
porque está 3 de smith gostam 3d e jogos
controle de mídia gosta os computadores
custam muito bom
a empresa em causa a marca em causa foi
a toscana clientes não duplicou mas
quase nos dois anos de campanha embora
pequeno problema
depois de venderem a toques chamados
amigos 15 anos e que chega um imenso nos
homens de 25 e os 40 ganhou o rato
ganhou a vaga porque para as pessoas nas
31 principais piadas e as coisas que ela
sabe da nova contagem em minas gerais e
medidas ora não sei quem é fã do ronaldo
que aconteceu foi o fim dos anos em maio
acontece na agência onde estava desde o
seu início e eu perdi mais uma conta não
falei a marca meses mas enfim
mas você está aí eu tentei o meu bem meu
pior e portanto time chegava aqui na
semana passada estava eu
pressionado pela organização precisamos
de um tema e precisamos apresentação e
meu instinto é a hora de mostrar as
piores coisas que fizeste o boys 10 e
bom
as duas uma ou é uma boa ideia e vocês
viram ou então se tivesse uma muito mais
ainda para ver se quiser mostrar os
erros do extinto em personalização o
filme mostra uma cesta a apresentação
que fiz
está mais ou menos feita coisa estou 57
56 segundos e portanto obrigado